southwest medical hospice volunteers
continue to provide comfort for our
community when it's needed the most
as a thank you let's honor this month's
hospice hero
jessica take a look
my name is jessica corvis i'm a hospice
volunteer with southwest medical
associates
i'm here at sunset park because i think
it's one of the
more beautiful places in las vegas and
it was also where i chose to bring
my lab when we
when she was on dog hospice and we were
getting ready to say goodbye to her
we brought her here and so it's a really
special place
for me personally sometimes i come here
after
i've seen patients and i just need some
quiet time
in a peaceful place and i look i listen
to the birds and i
watch the ducks and it's just a very
calming environment
when i got out of the navy the job that
i had didn't translate very well to a
civilian position
so i got a job as a cna and
i worked with some really great nurses
in that field and i really enjoyed
that work so when i was working in
nursing i
typically did alzheimer's care long-term
care end-of-life care
i didn't work for hospice specifically
when i was in nursing
so i i had been around it but i hadn't
experienced it for myself
when covid happened i was at home on
facebook like everyone
and i saw the ad to volunteer for
southwest medical associates
and i filled out the interest form which
took about a minute
from there there's some things you have
to do to prepare to actually volunteer
some training some background checks and
things and once i completed those things
i started volunteering my
typical contribution is is with the
patient
directly but there are a lot of services
that hospice offers
it can be doing things for the family so
that they can be with the patients
instead
there's a lot of services after they've
already gone through their loss
that they can take advantage of support
wise later
and then there's a lot of administrative
things that people can do so there's a
very wide spectrum of services that
hospice does offer
and i think that sometimes people just
associate it with
an ending and a bad time and certainly
it is
happening at a bad time but i also think
that
what hospice brings is that they make
that bad time or that sad time
easier better more comfortable kinder
i've definitely enjoyed the experience
i think that there's again something
that
anyone can find a place if they're
interested in doing it
for just a few hours a week or a few
hours a month they can participate in
that
it can be as close to dealing with the
patient or is removed from that as
they're comfortable with i'm really
proud to be a hospice hero with
southwest medical associates
i think they do a great service for the
community and
they help people at their most
vulnerable moments
congrats and thank you jessica for more
information on southwest medical hospice
or to become a volunteer yourself
call 702-671-1111 or visit the website
on your screen
remember there are virtual and in-person
opportunities as a hospice volunteer
we're going to be right back with
breaking news and an update on the
military plane crash